all right well welcome everyone we're
excited to see you all here um my name
is James Blair uh and I work as a
product manager at posit for cloud
Integrations and I'm excited to be here
with you all today to talk about some of
the recent work that we've done with
data bricks and the partnership that we
have with them and and what we're
excited about I'm joined today by rafy
Kuran who is um a product specialist at
data bricks and we'll be walking through
some of the the datab bricks perspective
on the partnership as well as the work
that we're doing together so I'm
actually going to turn the time over to
him to get things started today but
we're excited to be here with you
all okay awesome thank you so much James
so um at data bricks I'm going to go
into a little bit of who we are and uh
we're all about so our our mission is to
democratize data and AI to the entire
world and we uh our strategy that we use
to basically accomplish this Miss
mission is twofold first we have created
three very successful open source
projects Apache spark which is scalable
in-memory data processing Delta Lake
which is scalable data storage and
management and mlflow which is used to
manage the entire machine learning life
cycle in addition to this commitment to
open source we also have developed a
managed service that is beloved by many
of our customers we have over 6,000
employees across the world we're very
successful thankfully in terms of our
revenue and investment from Top firms
around the world and we're the inventor
of the data lake house Paradigm as well
as a Pioneer in generative Ai and we're
very fortunate to have been recognized
uh for for these accomplishments
now what I would like to uh begin to go
into is sort of you know our view on
data niai is that it's Universal and
everyone already knows that this has
impacted every single industry every
single sector of the economy and we
believe that the the companies that kind
of win in their industry will become
themselves data and AI
companies this is uh easier said than
done though and if you look at what data
niai means it's actually collection of
very different but related Technologies
so for example you have everything from
data warehousing inbi to streaming
real-time analytics data science machine
learning um and then you have to govern
all these different sort of use cases
and Technologies um not to mention that
you have the emergence of generative Ai
and the promise that that it kind of
brings to the table so it's very very
hard for organizations to kind of wrap
their heads around all this and and make
them you know successful with all of
this um our effort has really been to
simplify all these things and we've done
so with the data lake house so if you're
not so familiar with the lake house let
me just kind of walk you through it
quickly so the concept of a lak house is
essentially it's a portmanto of data
warehouse and uh data lake so you have
the uh structured data and performance
and consistency that you have with the
data warehouse alongside the
unstructured data and sort of the open
nature of a data lake so our our data
lake house is built on an open data Lake
that basically you use cloud object
storage S3 ADLs GCS to store all of your
data and then you can unify your data
under uh one single storage and
management system which is Delta lake is
the underlying technology for that once
you have all of your data in storage and
you're managing it with Delta Lake then
you can secure and govern it with unity
catalog and then once you've secured and
governed your your data all of your data
one copy of the data then you can kind
of unlock these different pillars of
data and Ai and and analytics right so
we kind of pioneered this concept in
2020 and we're we're really really
excited and happy to announce that like
this has been pretty successful we've
had you know 74% of goldber Enterprises
have adopted the lak house architecture
so this really speaks to kind of the
power of it and and sort of the um the
Simplicity and unification of
it all right now now that you understand
a little bit about what a data lake
house is it's this open Unified
foundation for all of your data what
happens when you combine this type of
foundation with generative AI so how
does that change things we think that
this actually introduces a new type of
data platform and that is the data
intelligence platform the concept of a
data intelligence platform really does
further the democrac ization of of data
nii makes it more accessible to more
people than ever
before so practically like how does that
work out right what does what does this
really mean practically so I want to
touch on two elements that that this
really kind of means the first is is
that obviously you want to be able to
use generative AI to understand the
semantics of your data so that you can
ask questions of your data in natural
language that's a huge part of what a
data intelligence platform is and we are
building data bricks to support that
type of interaction with data the other
way that you can kind of use generative
AI is to use open source models and
combine it with your own personal data
so that you can build applications on
top of it right so that's sort of what
I'm going to focus on a little bit more
today when uh when we go through a demo
but rest assured that datab bricks is
working on these two different sort of
um components of a data intelligence
platform both for end users who want to
ask questions of their data and for
developers that want to build with
generative AI
okay so uh how do you access this data
intelligence platform using posit
products so James is going to focus a
lot on on this question and I and I'm
going to show a little bit as well but I
want to talk really
quickly before before I hand it over to
James I want to uh just talk quickly
about the products that I'm going to be
using from data bricks that enable this
type of
activity so the first is going to be
datab bricks connect version two datab
bricks connect is a lightweight client
library that you can install on your
laptop or any server that you want to be
running a remote connection to datab
bricks and it allows you to use Apache
spark in a very simple way so it's very
very useful when you're working in your
IDE and you want to kind of do
exploratory work or development work uh
in the comfort of your IDE but it's also
very useful when you want to develop a
data app like a shiny app or a streamlet
app or something like that and you want
to be able to access data bricks and all
the data that's in there that's secure
that's governed all that kind of stuff
so that's the first thing I'm going to
be showing you
today the second thing I'm going to be
showing you is the data bricks extension
for vs code I'm going to show you how
easy it is to get set up how you can
find it in the uh VSS code
Marketplace how it kind of lets you use
all the features that you like about bs
code but still be able to access and run
code against data bricks and work with
the data that you have
there and then lastly I'm going to be
showing a little bit about datab bricks
model serving this is our online
real-time inference for machine learning
models it is fully managed including
support for gpus it's oneclick
deployment of models it's uh serverless
it scales up and down seamlessly we've
done special optimizations specifically
for serving large language models and
you can also set up monitoring of the
the inference the you can set up tables
that basically collect the the
inferences that you're making and um
help you set up monitoring sort of just
like out of the box with a few clicks
okay now I'm going to turn it over to
you
James hey thanks rafie I think it's
clear that datab breaks has a lot to
offer and a lot to bring to the table
with this data intelligence platform and
we're excited to talk about the ways in
which posit has worked closely with
datab bricks to make the experience for
our joint customers even better um to to
highlight this uh I want to talk a
little bit about the history of closet
as a company which may be familiar to
some of you it may not be familiar to
some of you so just to give some context
of of where posit comes from and how we
fit into this picture um I think we'll
be good let me sh let me start my
slideshow here perfect okay
so posit has its roots in open source
software primarily in the form of the r
Studio IDE so if you've ever used the r
language odds are at some point you've
used the r Studio IDE which is where
pait has come from right historically um
we continue to be the maintainers of
this open source today and it is the
preferred development environment for
developers and data scientists that are
working with the r language we also
contribute heavily to the open source
Community through a variety of Open
Source packages these include a number
of popular R packages like the tidyverse
and its collection of packages for data
analysis and um data science shiny for
interactive applications quto for for
dashboarding and for reproducible
reporting reticulate allows our users to
work with python directly from the r
language um and many many more one of
the things that's exciting as as we look
at at where posit has been and where
we're going is our renewed and continued
investment into not only R but also
python so that we focus not just ex
exclusively on a single language but
instead we focus on promoting open
source technology for data
scientists regardless of whatever
language that might that might be in
just a little bit of historical context
and this is not comprehensive at all but
just to give some context as to as to
what posit is as a company and who we
are in 2011 is when the r Studio IDE was
first introduced again as an open source
tool that's available to download and it
continues to exist today as an open-
source desktop installation that anybody
can go and use that's something that we
firmly believe in is is providing those
open source tools to give anyone in the
in the world access to the tools
necessary to be be data literate and to
make informed decisions based on on data
they have access to shiny the package
for uh building interactive web
applications and R was introduced in
2012 our first enterprise software where
we were charging customers to run
software in an Enterprise environment
with additional features that were
attractive to the Enterprise we're
introduced in 2014 and then in 2020 we
announced that we were becoming a public
benefit Corporation and included in that
effort is some specific promises that we
make to our community as part of our our
company Mission and then in
2022 the company rebranded from from our
studio which had been the name of the
company up until that point to pause it
so if you've ever worked with r Studio
the company we are one of the same uh we
just now go by the name of posit which
helps us again kind of push forward our
mission of Open Source data science
regardless of the language of
choice one thing that's pretty unique
about how posit operates is that a lot
of what we do today on the engineering
side is focused on open source
technology and open source packages
again we continue to support the open
source RC IDE that continues to be very
very popular amongst data scientists and
users but then we also have this growing
collection of packages that we work to
support as well that we firmly believe
that this open- Source commitment is
beneficial across the board it helps
users get early access to tools and
technology that enable them to be
successful in working with data at no
Financial cost um and then it also
enables them to take those tools into a
professional context into a commercial
environment where we can support those
tools with our Enterprise products that
that customers purchase and then that
purchase that that um income that we
receive there gets reinvested back into
the open source side and this is
something that we refer to often as The
Virtuous cycle we give to the open
source side and that eventually promotes
commercial adoption of of the tools that
we
provide when we talk about the
commercial side or the uh Enterprise
side of posit there's really three main
components that we'll talk about each
each of these will be highlighted to
some extent in our conversation today as
we talk about data brecks but just to
give those who may be unfamiliar an idea
we offer a tool called posit workbench
which enables uh users to access common
data science development environments
through a browser in a centrally managed
type of way so through posit workbench
you have access to the r Studio
development environment vs code Jupiter
notebook jupyter lab and there's a
number of different ways that posit
workbench can be configured to run
Within organization and can be designed
architecturally to fit within whatever
type of environment an organization's
running in as a compliment to posit
workbench we offer posit connect which
serves as a bridge between the
developers and the data scientists and
the end users so posit connect allows
developers to publish and share the work
that they've done inside of a
development environment whether that
work is something interactive like a
shiny application that was built in r or
a streamlet application that was built
in python or or even a web API that was
built in R python those can be published
to posit connect and then other users of
the organization whether they're
business users decision makers they may
be Downstream processes that are
consuming apis those can be those can
then utilize the work that's been done
by the data scientists and the
developers because it's hosted and
shared in a central location that's
secured and governed according to the
rules of the of the business and the
rules of the
organization as a kind of behind the
scenes component to all this we also
offer posit package manager which
enables organizations to provide a
secure and um essentially regulated way
to to have users access R in Python
packages organizations can Define which
packages are part of their ecosystem uh
posit work excuse me posit package
manager supports snapshotting by date so
if I had an analysis or a thing that I
worked on two years ago and I need to
roll back to packages as they were at
that point in time
posit package manager makes all that
very simple very straightforward and is
a benefit to organizations where
reproducibility and security are most
important so what we'll talk about now
as we as we move forward today is how
all of these different pieces the open
source side the commercial side how does
all this work together with data bricks
and what is it that we're doing today
and what is it that we plan to do in the
future to make life easier for those
organizations that happen to be using
posit and data bricks
together collectively we ref refer to
the the commercial side or the
commercial products that we offer as
posit team right and again that that
idea of posit team is posit workbench
posit connect posit package manager and
what we look forward to and what we're
going to talk through today is how posit
team can sit alongside this data
intelligence platform that Roy's
described and interact through a variety
of different ways with that platform and
leverage all the data BRS has to offer
in terms of data governance security
compute power distributed computing all
that datab bricks has to to bring to the
table model serving all these things
that rafy's touched on already we can
leverage those and make use of them from
inside of these different products that
that posit offers and we can do that
through open source packages we can do
that through specific things that we've
introduced into the r Studio ID IDE that
we'll that we'll highlight in just a
moment but the idea is posit team can
work directly with tools and
functionality of the datab breaks data
intelligence platform today and in the
future and we're excited to show a
little bit of what that looks like so
I'm going to turn things back over to
rafie who's going to walk us through
some examples of using VSS code inside
of posit workbench and how that works
today with with
database okay awesome thank you James
All right so I'm gonna go through a
quick demo here and I want to start with
posit workbench so for people who may
not be so
familiar you sign into posit workbench
and then you are able to basically
launch different sessions for different
development environments that you would
like to use so you can create a new
jupyter notebook session jupyter lab our
studio if you want to develop an r and
then of course vs code which is
preferred by many for for python as well
as Jupiter now I've already gone ahead
and um created a vs code session so if
if but if I wanted to obviously we could
create more and I could have multiple
different IDs going on at the same
time my uh vs code session is over here
and I want to start off by just showing
how we can get access to the vs code
extension Okay so so from vs code I can
come over here to the extensions Tab and
then if you just search for data bricks
in the marketplace you'll find the very
first one is owned by the datab Bri
organization you can install it and then
you're good to go so it's it's that
simple once you once you have the
extension installed you'll see this icon
over here in the left nav bar and you'll
the first time that you open this up
you'll basically be prompted to
configure it which will ask you you know
which datab bricks workspace do you want
to sign into so you can specify that URL
for your particular workspace
here once you choose that you have the
option of signing in Via OA or you can
use the the datab Brick CLI I've already
gone ahead and installed the data brick
CLI here actually James has done that on
my behalf and um I've configured and
I've logged into Data bricks through
through the CLI as well point being that
it's very very simple to sign in to
datab Bricks through the UI just by
clicking you don't have to go through
and um mess with environment variables
if you don't want
to and um once once you do that once you
set up the connection to the datab Brix
workspace you'll see this this um left
Page over here basically or left window
basically be populated so we'll see what
workspace I'm connected to which cluster
in the workspace I'm connected to I can
actually browse the various clusters
that I may want to uh connect to and
choose which one I want to attach my
compute to or sorry attach my session to
and this is going to allow us to
basically use datab bricks connect and
run files holistically on this
particular compute resource that lives
in datab
bricks um the last thing I'm going to
cover I'm not going to do like an
exhaustive sort of view of the vs code
extension because of time constraints
but just to call it out you know you can
also choose a destination in the datab
bricks workspace where you can sync your
code to so this is very very helpful if
you want to um have relative paths work
when you run code on datab bricks from
vs code so you basically have a copy of
your code in datab bricks so that all
the relative paths will resolve
correctly but it's also helpful if you
want to do some kinds of development
work in data in in vs code and then you
want to maybe flip to data bricks to a
notebook to kind of use some of the
features that we have there as well so
you have an exact sort of High Fidelity
copy copy of your code in data bricks
2 all right so I'm going to start off um
I've already gone ahead and connected to
this particular this particular compute
and I'm going to go through a juper
notebook that I have uh showing how we
can use datab bre connect all right so
the first thing uh that we're going to
do just to remind everyone about datab
brakes connect this is essentially a
library that is installed on this uh
posit workbench server where this is
running in in the cloud outside of datab
bricks this is a remote connection and
we normally we just create a new spark
session and then any P spark code that
we use any spark code that we use in the
data frame API will be run remotely on
datab bricks if we were to run any local
like or any just pure python code that
would still be running on the the
machine where this is installed so it's
important to just keep that in mind that
datab BR connect allows you to use
Apache spark to to you know process data
in the cloud but anything that's not
using Apache spark is going to be
executed on the local
machine okay now one of the nice things
about the vs code extension is that it
has a particular integration with datab
bricks connect where if you're using the
a Jupiter notebook in vs code will
actually just create the spark session
for you so here you'll see I'm going to
read um from a UFO sightings table that
is in the art that is in my catalog
under the default schema and then the
UFO sightings table okay so I'm
accessing data that's in unity catalog
here I'm bringing it to pandas because I
just want it to render a little bit uh
more nicely and this is a very
interesting data set because it's
essentially uh you know records of UFO
sightings in um in the United States you
can see you know which particular or
sorry not just the United States which
particular country which state what time
it was and then the thing that I want to
focus on actually is the text so the
text is the actual report itself like
what did someone
observe so I live in New Jersey so I'm
going to filter down to the the state of
New Jersey and we're just going to take
a look at the text of one of these uh
sightings okay so we have an object
object like a plane without
wings uh and and so on and so forth
right there's a lot of a lot of
descriptive uh text
here it would be a little bit
challenging to kind of go through and
read all of these reports and you know
draft up an analysis of you know what
what are the similarities and what are
the discrepancies between the various
reports I think this is a very very good
use case to basically take all this text
Data give it to a language model and ask
it to summarize it for us so I'm going
to show how we can do that with um datab
bricks model
serving so the model serving product on
datab bricks is remarkable because it
allows you to essentially serve via rest
API um every type of machine learning
model that you would want so everything
from classic machine learning everything
that we were so invested in up until the
the rise of generative AI um you can
serve all of those on um on datab bricks
this is going to be done in like a
secure and scalable way and this is also
applies to Foundation models so we do
the work to go get the best
state-of-the-art open source models so
that you don't have to go do all that
research and we'll actually have those
hosted in your environment for you and
you'll be able to call those very simple
very simply and I'm going to show you
that and then third is that we can
actually provide a secure uh route or
Gateway that allows you to manage if you
if you want to use um commercial
offerings from like open AI or other
companies you want to manage that under
the same place that you manage your
custom models or or Foundation open
source models we provide the the means
for you to do that as well so we can
kind of bring all these different kinds
of machine learning models into a single
serving
product all right now Foundation models
in particular these are the
state-of-the-art open source models
they're really good for summarization
for Content generation and if you want
to build a chatbot using uh rag or
resources uh resource augmented
generation and just FYI this is per
token based pricing the foundation
models API in preview if you're
interested in this kind of thing you
like what we're showing you today you
should definitely reach out to your data
rcks uh rep now let's actually take a
look at it
okay all right so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to take just eight
observations from the uh data frame that
we created before and we're just going
to take the text for those eight
observations all right so here is these
UFO sightings from New
Jersey we have eight observations here
now what I want to do is I want to
access a l 270b chat model that we have
hosted in datab bricks and just call it
from vs code right here so I'm going to
install a I've already gone ahead and
install this I'm not going to run this
right now but we're going to install
this inference
SDK and then let's start this here we'll
import this chat
completion we'll Define The Prompt which
is going to be your helpful assistant
you're going to summarize UFO sightings
and explain the the similarities and
differences between them summarize them
in three bullet points we want want this
to be um pretty Snappy and pretty uh
concise and then to actually make that
call we just have you know several lines
of code very very simple where we pass
in the system prompt and we pass in the
sightings object that we created before
that blob of text and then here's our
response right so we have three bullet
points it says all the sightings
describe objects or lights in the sky
that can't be identified as man-made or
natural many of them describe as moving
quickly or hovering and some describe as
disappearing or changing direction
suddenly and and um let's take a look at
some of the differences some of the
sightings describe oops some of the
sightings describe the objects as being
very large While others describe them as
being relatively small and so on so I
think this is a really really nice way
to kind of combine data bricks model
serving with a challenging data set and
leverage s some of the superpowers that
uh llms actually have okay one last
thing I want to call out here before I
move on is notice how I didn't have to
specify any credentials or anything like
that when making these API calls so all
of the data breaks SD K in the last year
that have come out and they've been
designed to reuse credentials that are
created when you sign in with ooth or
when you use the datab Bri CLI so this
is a much more secure and easy way to
use these
sdks all right now the the second sort
of um example that I want to show you is
using the python SDK so datab bricks
recently released a pure python SDK for
interacting with the data expressed API
and I want to show you how simple it is
to call
a uh language model on datab bricks
using the python SDK so we'll import the
workspace client from the datab works
python SDK we'll instantiate the
workspace client we're going to say what
is the serving endpoint model serving
endpoint that we're going to call and
then we'll say our prompt right in this
case we're not looking at the UFO data
anymore we're going to be calling a
model that actually has um been built on
on top of a rag architecture that
indexes all the latest data
documentation stores it in a vector
database and then uses that uh those
embeddings to actually return a more
accurate response to us when we query
it querying it is also super simple so
we use the workspace client the uh
serving endpoint service and then we
pass in the query which is go hit this
model and then here's our prompt that we
want to pass now for this one I'm going
to use the uh run python file
functionality here in vs
code and wait a few
seconds and we should be able to um to
see the results
here okay so what is uh what does our
language model have to say about
this data braks model serving deploys
your ml flow machine learning models and
exposes them as rest API endpoints
serverless compute resources easy
configuration High availability and
scalability dashboards monitoring all
sounds pretty great okay um now I'm just
going to show quickly and I'm going to
hand it back over to
James so this is in datab bricks itself
this is the model that we were calling
and you can see some of the dashboards
that uh that exist here right beyond the
scope of the presentation to go into
detail here but I just wanted to show
how this is the model that that we were
calling
there okay so to
recap we showed how you can launch vs
code in posit workbench how you can
access data brick byy installing the vs
code extension you can use datab bricks
connect to have interactive um sessions
with the data that's being managed in uh
datab bricks and unity catalog and then
we also showed how you can access datab
bricks model serving both through the
the python SDK and then also through
that foundations models um
API all right and now I will pass it
back over to you
James excellent thanks rafie for walking
us through that demo I think again it's
it's clear that data bricks has a lot to
offer in regards to the ways in which we
interact with modern tools in the data
stack and it's really great to see some
of those become more and more available
to users from whatever environment they
want to be in whether it's vs code or
something else and we're going to
continue that theme here as we talk
about some new changes that we're
introducing into deposit workbench so a
lot of what we're going to walk through
here in a moment is going to be made
available in the upcoming December
release of posit workbench if you happen
to be a posit workbench customer
and there's some also there's also some
open source components here that we'll
we'll talk through as well the first
thing I want to highlight is when I'm in
pait workbench if I go to start a new
session I'm presented with this option
to choose like rafie demonstrated
earlier which editor which environment I
want to run my session in whether it's
jupter notebook or lab or Ps code
whatever the case might be um but
there's this new portion down below the
session name where I can choose a datab
breaks workspace that I'm going to want
to authenticate into these workspaces
are configured by an admin so an admin
would go through and Define what
workspaces users would have access to
and then I can select from whichever
workspace I want to select from whether
it's none or a predefined one and then
choose to sign into that workspace once
I click sign in this will transfer me
over to another browser window where I
will sign into datab bricks using
whatever mechanism is used within my
organization on our side we use SSO and
so I would go through that whole flow to
get signed into Data breaks once that's
happened
pait workbench will manage a specific
token credential for me that I won't
need to worry about and the nice thing
about that me and the benefit of this is
as a user I don't need to worry about
downloading or managing a personal
access token to gain access to data
bricks from within posit workbench it's
all managed behind the scenes for me and
automatically kept up to dat once I've
gone through this signin process here
from the from the new session launch
screen once we've started this session
we'll be dropped into the r IDE so if
you've used the open source version the
version that's available on posit
workbench feels essentially identical
and familiar I have the ability to
browse files and packages and other
things that I might find interesting in
here I'm going to go ahead and open a
project that contains some content that
we're going to walk through as as part
of this demonstration and then I want to
highlight um one of the things that's
going to be new in this upcoming release
of posit workbench if I look up here in
the top right hand corner I have a
number of different panes that I can
open up there's a new pane however
called Data bricks and if I click on
this new pane this will open up a view
into my datab bricks compute console so
essentially what I am able to do here is
I'm able to see what compute clusters I
have access to on datab bricks I can see
what status they have whether they're
running clusters whether they're stopped
whether they in their process of
starting up or shutting down and if I
want to I can click on any of these so
let's take a look at this old cluster
here at the top of my list I can click
on any of these and find additional
details about the cluster including its
ID what its policy is information about
the resources assigned to that cluster
all this is made available directly here
inside of the RS St IDE within posit
workbench and again this is specific to
posit workbench so to be transparent
this is not something that will come to
the open source version of the r Studio
IDE but rather is something that is
specific to to posit workbench the
advantage of this is that it kind of
twofold one is as a datab bricks user if
I want to run some workload on datab
bricks I can start the cluster I want to
run that workload against directly from
with the NR Studio I don't need to log
in the data breakes UI I don't need to
navigate some other system I can do
everything I need to directly from
within the development environment
window and then once I've once I've
started a cluster so let's take this old
cluster for example once I've started a
cluster I can easily connect to it by
clicking on this connection icon this
will open up a dialogue box that pre
populates all the information that's
necessary to make the connection to this
cluster and again one of the advantages
of the fact that posit workbench is
managing my datab breaks credentials for
me is that I don't need to input any
sort of password I don't need to input
any sort of key or token here all of
that is automatically passed through
from workbench to the connection when
this connection is made you'll see here
that this cluster ID was automatically
populated in this connection dialogue it
tells me okay the data breaks runtime
for this cluster is 13.3
and then it informs me here that the
python environment necessary for dbr
13.3 isn't available locally right so so
datab bricks connect is something that
rafie talked about a little bit and
that's the tool that we use to connect
remotely into these data brick sessions
or these data bricks compute clusters to
orchestrate workloads there but there
are some local dependencies necessary in
order to have that functionality I need
to have a version of data breaks connect
bring locally and that version of data
breaks connect needs to align with the
version of data bricks runtime on the
cluster that I'm connecting to so all of
these checks H happen automatically and
so in this case this is a cluster that I
just started this morning for this
Purpose with an older version of of
datab bricks runtime so
13.3 and it tells me I don't have the
right python dependencies in place I'll
need to install those so we'll go
through that process in just a moment it
tells me down here look at your
credentials are being managed by
workbench we've already passed the
credential everything is good to go for
connecting the only thing missing is the
local python dependencies that I need to
make this connection if I go ahead and
click okay here then this will launch
down here inside
of we did this right let's go back
through here one more time there we
go let's copy this to the clipboard okay
so if we run this code here to make the
connection
copy I'll try this one more
time
all
right okay so if we run this code here
inside of our console in in our studio
we'll get a prompting to install the
right python dependencies for this
particular connection so here in this
case it says look we don't have the
right version of dependencies necessary
to support a connection to a cluster
running dbr 13.3 do you want to install
those dependencies and we can hit yes
here and this will go through the
process of creating a virtual
environment on my specific to my user in
this case specific to my user on posit
workbench that contains all the correct
dependencies necessary to create a
connection to this specific cluster now
if I were to create another cluster or
try to connect to another cluster that
was also running a version of datab
breaks runtime the same version of data
breaks runtime so in this case 13.3 it
would know that this environment already
exists and use this pre-existing virtual
environment so I'm not I don't need to
recreate virtual environments every time
I connect but rather each time I connect
to a new version of datab brakes runtime
I'll be prompted to install an updated
version of the the python dependencies
and those will be isolated in their own
virtual environment so that I can reuse
whichever one I need to for the Clusters
that I might want to
access you'll notice up here on the top
right hand corner now once I've made
this connection it automatically opened
to this connections pane this
connections pane now shows me a view
into Unity catalog so I can through the
different catalog schemas and tables
that I have available to me on the datab
brick side and view specific details
about those tables so if I wanted to
look at the UFO data that rafie was
talking about I could come in and expand
this out and see okay here's this new
Fork reports data or this new Fork
reports table it's it's inside of this
demos catalog and this new Fork schema
and then this will open up in just a
moment and show me a preview of the
different uh the different columns that
that table has the different values that
that table
has this is all everything that we've
walked through here with the exception
of this data bricks pane over here on
the right hand side everything that
we've walked through here is a function
of the sparkly RR package which is an
open source package so being able to
connect to data bricks from a local art
process using sparkly art is something
that's available in that open source
package it's just this data brakes pane
that's specific to the pait workbench
release that's coming later this
month that also includes just to
highlight that also includes the python
dependency management that we talked
about so sparklyr will do a bunch of
checks behind the scenes to ensure that
everything is in place locally to
facilitate the proper type of connection
into a datab brakes
environment once I've created this
connection I'm actually going to go
ahead
and close out of this one
here and I want to walk through a and a
little bit of an example of some of the
things that we can do so we can there's
there's two two different ways that we
can interact with or create these
connections into Data bricks to work
with the data that's being stored there
one is through spark layer which we just
showcase and here's another example of
how I would make that connection past
the cluster ID and then the the key here
is this method is data breaks connect
this is the argument that lets sparkly
are know how we're trying to make this
connection so I can go ahead and run
this again this will create a connection
to a separate cluster you'll notice this
cluster is running 14.0 and I did not
need to install sort of python
dependencies because they're already in
place in my environment in fact if we
look at
here here I can list the virtual
environments that are available for me
and I can see that I have three
different virtual environments specific
to data bricks that are all specific to
different versions of data breaks
runtime and again spark layer will help
facilitate the automatic instantiation
of these if
necessary in addition to connecting
through sparklyr we're also excited to
announce that we will begin offering a
data break odbc connector to our
professional customers here in the next
short little while and this datab bricks
obbc yeah this datab bricks obbc driver
will be made available alongside the
collection of existing obbc drivers that
we offer to customers what that means is
if I come in and I say let's go back to
connections let's create a new
connection here you can see I have a
long list of available connection types
and if I scroll there we go down to the
middle of this list I can see that data
bricks is listed in here as one of those
drivers that I can connect to it's also
worth noting that this datab bricks
connect dbr 13 plus is this is a way to
connect directly from the connections
pane with the sparklyr package so if I
wanted to connect through sparklyr I
have a number of different ways that I
can facilitate that one of which is
through the connections pane which will
bring up this dialogue similar to what
we saw
previously if I go to the data bricks
obbc driver here in this list this will
prompt me for the HTTP path that I need
to connect to the cluster cluster that I
want to connect to or to the um SQL
Warehouse on data breaks that I want to
connect to and I can retrieve that
information from the data breakes comp
or the data brakes
UI here's an example of how we can
connect to that how we can make an obbc
connection into Data bricks and I want
to highlight one additional thing here
that's that we're excited about if I if
I connect traditionally so a typical
obbc connection from R would rely on the
obbc package and then specifically would
rely on the BC function from that
package to facilitate a connection and
then that allows me to pass in things
like what driver do I want to use and
what connection requirements or what um
connection string details need to be
presented or provided to that driver to
create the connection to this data
source in the case of data breaks I
actually need to provide a lot of detail
I need to provide the driver name the
host where where the host where my data
breakes um where where data brakes is
being run the the port the HTTP path the
catalog I want to connect to I need to
define whether I'm using SSL there's
this Thrift transport argument I need to
Define what off mechanism I'm using and
provide a user ID and password whether
that's a username and password
combination or a token and the and the
the personal access token that I'm
supplying um but I have a lot of details
that need to be provided in order to
create a connection to data bricks well
because we've done a lot of work inside
of workbench to simplify things like
credential management and other
components necessary to access data
breaks we're introducing a new function
to the obbc package in an upcoming
release called Data bricks and this
function exists to help facilitate
connections to datab Bricks through obbc
whether that driver is the obbc driver
that you install from us or it's the
obbc driver and connector that you
install and download and install from
datab bricks themselves with this new
obbc datab bricks function we can get
rid of essentially everything that we
saw in the previous connection string
and instead just Supply the HD key path
that we need and that's it right and so
to highlight this if we run this chunk
of code right here we'll see that we
have an obbc connection into Data bricks
and this obbc connection will give me a
similar view into Unity catalog as what
we saw with sparkly are so once again I
can expand out and I can look at okay
here's this new Fork schema here's this
table inside of there here's the
different values that are included in
that
table and if we come back here we can
see that we now have two different
connections we have a obbc connection
into data braks and then we have a spark
Layar connection into Data brakes that
are both being supported from this local
environment once we've created these
connections into the datab bricks
environment we can create local
references to data tables that might
exist in The datab Brak environment so
for example if I run this new Fork
command here or if I if I run this line
of code here that uses the the tible
function or the TPL function to
reference the data inside of inside of
data break so notice that I'm
referencing demos new fork and then the
new Fork reports this will create a
local reference that points to that data
inside of data braks in fact we can see
this because if we run the head function
which would typically return the first
six rows of a given data set and then we
run show query this will show me how
this ends up being translated on the
back end in the spark SQL that gets
executed on datab brecks and the results
come back into my environment the key
here and the benefit of this is that I
can keep all of my data in data bricks
as long as I need to and work with it
there and then when necessary I can move
whatever summarized version of the data
I need back into my R Studio
environment so if we wanted to like for
example right we had this this UFO
sightings data if we wanted to explore
this data and gain some insight from it
we could do something like take the new
Fork data and filter by date time and
then calculate by month how many UFO
sightings there were from the data set
and then we could explore what that
might look like we can keep again we can
keep all the data inside of data bricks
to perform the aggregation of this and
then finally collect the resulting
aggregation into our R session and then
work with other tools with an R like
ggplot for example to create some sort
of a visualization of whatever it is
that we're investigating right in this
case we're saying how many how many UFO
sightings were there by month by year in
this data set and so we can see if we
look at this there's you know not a lot
up until about 2000 then things started
to increase
uh in 2010 maybe 28 2009 things really
kind of ramped up but have maybe died
down a little bit in the past couple of
years we could also do you know we could
extend this even further and we could do
other analysis we could do other
exploration but I want to highlight a
couple of other things here in the in
the brief time that we have one is as a
data scientist this is how I typically
spend my time I work interactively with
some sort of a data set until I find
some insight or actionable piece of
information from that data set at that
point what I want to do is I want to be
able to share that Insight or that
whatever it is that I found with other
members of my organization that can take
a number of different forms I could be
an email I could build a PowerPoint
presentation I could do what you know
there's a number of I can send a slack
message there's all kinds of different
ways that I can distribute information
but what we found at posit is that the
most effective way to distribute
information is to provide something
that's reproducible and that's lasting
that users can come back to and
reference whenever they need to and it's
difficult to do that with something like
an email that can get buried in an inbox
or a slack message that can get buried
in in a slack
thread to help support that idea we have
well what I've talked briefly about
earlier uh a product called posit
connect and posit connect would allow us
to do something like here's an example
where I can take a quto document so this
is quto which is a kind of successor to
to arm mark down a way of interspersing
code with with plain text and pros this
is actually I'm not going to dive too
deeply into this but this is a preview
of a new feature that's coming in the
next release of quto that allows you to
create dashboards using the quto package
so I can create this document here that
contains R code interspersed with plain
text if I look at this document locally
so I'm just going to go ahead and render
this this will create a dashboard that
allows me to view some key summaries of
this in this case this UFO data and once
I've created this dashboard locally
right once I've got all the code working
and I have this rendering and and
looking the way that I want it to look I
can easily publish and distribute this
through something like posit connect
once this is distributed on posit
connect let's open this up here so
here's an example of this dashboard I
can see overtime percentage of reported
sightings by different countries I can
also break this down by day of the week
or by hour of the day looks like most
signings happen in the evening which is
to be expected much harder to see bright
UFOs in the middle of the day I can see
a summary of the different types of ways
in which these sightings are described
as well as the different ways in which
the like shape of the UFO has changed
over time um over here on the right hand
side and then I can also view some
additional details about the data here
so this gives me a really nice way to
package up some information that might
be highly relevant to different members
of my organization and then share and
distribute it with them what that looks
like is let me come back in here for
just a moment if I there's a couple of
different there's a number of different
ways you can deploy and share content on
depit connect but if you use the RS
connect package there's a couple of key
advantages particularly when it comes to
working with datab brick supported
content like a CTO dashboard that
queries data on the datab brick side and
that is I can Define both the python
environment that I want posit connect to
use so one of the advantages of posit
connect is that it will Define whatever
environment I have locally including the
r packages and their versions and the
python packages in their versions and it
will send a definition of that
environment to posit connect when posit
connect tries to publish whatever it is
that I've submitted in this case that
would be this quto document it will
first recreate the environment it needs
to run that content and it will do this
in isolation so I do not have to worry
about managing a complex network of
dependencies on connect instead every
piece of content has its own collection
of dependencies there's a shared cach so
I'm not duplicating work but it means
that everything can operate in isolation
without interference with with other
content so if this dashboard uses some
version of of py spark that another
dashboard uses a different version of
pisar there's not going to be a conflict
when it comes to to publishing and
sharing on on posit connect the other
advantage of using this RS connect
package is that it allows me to pass
envi local environment variables in a
very secure way to posit connect so this
is how I can pass information about how
I'm making the connection to datab
Bricks so that posit connect can make
that connection
itself excuse
me if I look so here's an example
of this document this dashboard now
published and shared on posit connect
right and now I can come over here and I
can say let's add rafy to this
dashboard we could add other members of
our organization we could add groups and
users we could be very specific about
who has access to this dashboard we
could schedule this dashboard to refresh
every week or every day or however often
the underlying data is updating and
however often we want to be informed of
the latest UFO Trends we can Define all
of that here inside of posit connect and
end users can come visit this whenever
they want to it's at a it's a specific
URL that they can log into and
view just to highlight one other thing
that we could do in this in this kind of
same idea is we could also if we wanted
to provide something that was a little
bit more interactive and less static
than than the PTO dashboard we could
also offer a shiny application right so
we could build an interactive web
application in r or python we could
publish that application to posit
connect and that application would
enable users to come and investigate
this data on their own and ask questions
on their own so here's an example of a
shiny application using this data that's
being hosted on data bricks where we can
take a look at okay I live in Utah
here's the collection of UFO sightings
that have happened in Utah let's filter
to not 2010 let's come
let's say let's filter from 2012 until
now search through the
records I can zoom in over here take a
look let's see I live over kind of in
this area what is what do we have here
okay here's the report of this of this
particular UFO sighting right and this
type of interactivity allows end users
not just to ingest the work that that's
been done for them but also ask their
own questions and get their own answers
from the underlying data and all of the
data here is being stored and managed on
data bricks through the data governance
capabilities the datab bricks has to
offer and queries are being submitted
and and registered against the datab
brecks computed
by okay so let me let me just take a
minute and summarize um a little bit
about of what we've chatted through
right what do we have today well rafie
talked to us about vs code and some of
the changes that exist some of the
opportunities that exist within vs code
and datab Bricks the vs code extension
for for datab bricks we talked about our
studio and the data bricks paint and the
way in which uh posit workbench can
manage authentication and manage
credentials for datab bricks users and
these are all things that are available
either today or in the very near future
with the upcoming release of of posit
workbench we also talked a little bit
about sparkly R and all the new changes
we've introduced there there's been a
lot of work an incredible amount of work
that's gone into the sparklyr package
over the past few months to support this
new datab bricks connect functionality
inside of datab bricks and to allow and
enable our users to seamlessly create
these remote connections into the datab
bricks
environment and then finally we're
simplifying the ability to connect to
datab Bricks through obbc by providing
our own datab bricks driver for
customers and also introducing this
datab bricks specific function into the
obbc package that makes it much easier
to create these connections without
needing to worry about all the different
connection string specific
details now for the last couple of
minutes before we turn our time to
questions let's talk about the future
and this is what in particular gets me
very excited we we've talked a lot about
how we can use these two products
separately or these two different
platforms separately we can have posit
running somewhere inside of our
organization you could be using our
studio desktop and sparklyr to connect
to data bricks and execute workloads
there right there's all these different
paradigms but the key for everything
we've talked about so far is that the
assumption is data bricks is running
somewhere and posit stuff is running
somewhere else right maybe you're maybe
it's all in AWS maybe it's all in Azure
but it's separate in its in its
implementation and in its architecture
and we can see that in this diagram that
we chatted about earlier where we have
the datab bricks data intelligence
platform and then we have posit team and
there's a number of different ways that
they can interact through obbc sdks
sparkly apis whatever the case might be
but what we're looking forward to and
excited about is in the near future we
look to provide a way to run posit team
and posit products directly inside of
your data breaks infrastructure and
architecture through a platform called
Lake housee applications now Lake housee
applications is something that was
announced by datab bricks back in the
summer of this year but the idea is that
it's a way to support native thirdparty
applications running directly on your
data breakes infrastructure in this sort
of Paradigm there's no separation of
infrastructure and data stays within the
realm of data breaks when you're quering
and moving data from your data warehouse
day lake house into a session that's
running on our studio or into an
inmemory session that's running with BS
code everything will stay inside of that
data brick security governance layer
nothing's moving outside of that and
that's something that that we've heard
frequent feedback from customers on and
something that we're excited to look to
provide as we look towards towards the
future uh once again want to thank
everybody for your attendance today and
and say that we on the posit side as
well as I know that the folks that we
work with on the datab briak side are
exceptionally excited about the work
that's been done and the work that's
going to be done in this partnership as
we move forward if there's Curiosity on
your end if you're interested in in any
of the things we've discussed today
we're happy to have conversations about
both the current and future state of our
partnership to answer your questions to
collect your feedback now is a great
time to have those conversations because
we're just getting started in the
process of defining what it will look
like to run posit products on data
bricks and so if you have strong
opinions on how you'd like to see that
happen now is the time to to have those
conversations with us there's a number
of different resources available today
to help provide some additional
information along with what we chatted
about today the QR code on the screen
now will take you to a GitHub repository
that contains the slides the demo code
and everything that we walked through
today and then there's also a series of
links here that that you can visit from
the slides that that are available on on
that get
repository uh with that I'm going to
actually just turn the time over and
we'll take some time to answer questions
that have come in through the different
chat
forms okay yeah we have a bunch of we
have a bunch of
questions should go from the
top let's do it okay just catching up on
all the all the chat
things um okay how difficult is it to
also include other languages like Julia
or Mathematica um I'll answer this
question from the posit side briefly and
then Ro you might have some thoughts on
the Daybreak side um I know so I think
probably stems from the introduction
that I made to pait how we aim to
support open source data science and and
development regardless of the language
uh R and python have been the primary
drivers in that area for a long time who
knows what the next 10 15 50 years are
going to bring in that space um but we
may remain committed to paying attention
to what's happening and and providing
tools it's possible to use things like
Julia inside of some you know inside the
RC ID today to some extent um you know
you can write some Julia code and things
like that but it's it's not a first
class citizen in that regard same with
Mathematica um but but a lot of that's
just driven by we we try to pay
attention to what customers are asking
for and what sorts of Trends we're
observing and and so far that that's
been very clear that Python and R have
been the two that we do we plan to
continue to
support yeah I I would just add that
like on data bricks in particular uh
python SQL R and Scola are the supported
languages and I don't think there's any
plans to add Julia however you can
always install datab bricks is super
friendly to open source so you can
always install Julia and run it on datab
breaks yeah yeah and there's I will say
there's there's a number of additional
things similar to that on the on the um
posit side and on the r Studio IDE side
specifically right you can for example
in a CTO document you can have bash code
chunks you can have SQL code chunks you
can have Python and R code chunks kind
of inter spurts throughout the same
document um so there's there's some
interoperability there but but Julia and
mathematic aren't ones that are highly
prominent right now
okay we got another
one let me see is it good to have
package managers so that every developer
can share packages installed on R and
Python and don't need to install
packages for every developer um so so
package
manager like package management is an
interesting topic because there's
there's a number of different pieces to
the puzzle package manager um kind of
sits in the middle so so every package
comes from an upstream repository and
then when it's installed it gets
installed into a library that Library
can be scoped in a number of different
ways but that's the the gist of it and
package manager allows you to create
your own internal Upstream repository
where you can say Hey you know we this
is particularly beneficial for things
like regulated Industries where we might
say hey we we have requirements that
that prevent us from using these certain
packages or packages with this license
type or there's some new security
features that we're introducing deposit
package manager that will allow you to
to like run or like they will help
provide visibility into like
vulnerabilities and things like that
that may exist in different open source
packages and so package manager allows
you to say hey like as an organization
here's the packages we Define for our
users and then users would still install
them individually into their own
environments but they would be coming
from package manager rather than coming
from an unknown repository out there on
the open
internet okay we keep going oh oh
see oh and in datab breaks notebook you
can directly start a shiny out that is
true will will we be able to do that
with pi shiny as well um I don't know
right now that's uh something we have to
look into I haven't tried it and it may
have a very different um implementation
so I'm going to say for now I don't know
if people if people try it and it works
it' be great to great to
know okay next one can the vs code can
can V code be run on a local PC and
still connect to data bricks yes uh
totally um if whether you have vs code
running and posit workbench on like you
know a VM in the cloud or workbench
running on your
laptop um it doesn't really matter the
vs code extension will work um wherever
you have VSS code
installed then there was a followup
there oh it's okay keep
going
uh this one I don't know if we're going
to be able to answer how how does it
ensure that Library dependencies are
installed in both posit and datab
clusters so let's just talk about like
the library management you know in
general so data Brooks um again the code
that you're that I showed you with with
datab bur connect when you're you're
basically running spark command spark
data frame API um against remote datab
bur compute so that's going to be
limited to Apache spark if you want to
run more code on data breaks you can run
the entire file on a data BRS cluster
either as a job or as like a one-time
just quick submission to run it in a
batch process so in that case you do
need to make sure that the libraries
that you're you have installed locally
where your code runs locally will also
be present in in datab bricks the the
easiest way to do that today is to
probably go to the datab bricks UI and
install the packages on the cluster that
you want to that that match your local
environment if you want to do it
programmatically the easiest way to do
that is to use one of the sdks to um use
the the cluster API you can update the
the packages that are installed on the
cluster through the rest API that
way and I'll just add that like we're
looking into ways that we can
potentially use package manager to make
that all very simple but it's still
early uh okay I'll take this one so in
the future will I be able to easily
develop publish and share shiny
streamlet or Dash apps all natively in
data bricks that's something that we're
looking at very closely and I think with
Lakehouse apps and including with the
partnership with with posit that is
something that I think will happen in
the in the near future um I don't have
any firm timelines or anything like that
but it's uh you know data apps and
hosting data apps is something that's
like very very on our
mind I think this one's for you
James
um sure s r yeah I don't I don't really
I don't know what Sedona R is either
sorry I don't either maybe we can answer
that in the chat or or follow up let's
go to the next
question in general any open source
package that's not in datab bricks
runtime uh there's a set of Open Source
packages in R and python that are
installed out of the box with datab
bricks runtime anything that's not
included in that and it's an open source
you can install it if it's your custom
package you can install it so you can
always bring your own libraries and your
own code all right uh next question if a
datab BRI cluster has python libraries
installed that aren't available in the
runtime will those be included in the
environment created in workbench so sort
of going the other way like if I have
libraries in datab bricks and I'm
creating a new session in
workbench am I getting those libraries
in
workbench so I think the answer for that
today is is no you would have to get a
list of you'd have to programmatically
get a list of uh the packages that are
installed in on on the cluster on the
databas cluster and then once you had
that list you could install them in your
workbench environment but there's not
like an automatic sync of the execution
environment to that degree of um to that
resolution but there's a lot of
questions about that that's a really
it's you're you're touching upon like an
important um all these questions about
environment man management are very
important and it's something that we're
at data bricks at least we're looking to
solve those problems right
now okay uh next question can you set
this up to run the entire R process on
datab braks or do you have to only run
the spark pieces on data breaks and the
rest is local so today like I said
before the interactive remote connection
to datab breaks is spark only however
you can run your entire script or uh you
can run your entire script on datab
bricks in a batch process and then that
sync that I showed you with the vs code
extension that actually uh makes it so
that all of your relative paths will
will work and that includes for r as
well so um that is sort of where we're
at with that we are also in in an effort
to continuously make this experience
better and easier we're trying to figure
out ways to have the entire process run
on data bricks so that you don't have to
have this sort of like split brain
between some things run run on data
bricks and some things run locally so
we're we're aware of that complexity and
we're trying to uh resolve
it yeah I can take this one um timeline
for some of these features and and
things like that with posit and data
breaks so the things that were specific
to posit workbench that we showcase so
the authentication management and the
data bricks pain and things like that
that those will be made available in the
next release of posit workbench which is
which is expected this month the
sparklyr stuff is available today um
we're continuing to can make some
incremental improvements of that package
but but what we've chatted through um
should be should be available today you
may need the dev version of the package
for a little bit of time before it it
hits cran but but it's available um the
obbc stuff is the so for example that
datab bricks function from the obbc
package that we highlighted that will be
part of the open source obbc package it
just needs to be released to cray so if
you wanted to use that today you could
it just needs to be you just need to use
the development version of the package
until until the cran release goes out um
and then and then have access to a data
Bri driver either the one that data
brick provides or the one that will
begin providing to customers and and
that driver that we're going to be
providing to customers will be available
in the next few weeks as
well um yeah so let me I'll answer this
one and just reiterate that yes the
datab brick function from the obbc
package will be available via open
source I realized I left off a
significant portion of the previous
answer which is when we talk about
Lakehouse applications and running posit
products on data breaks and some of the
work that's going to happen between now
and then so one of the things that I
haven't mentioned yet is the the work
that we're doing right now to start
looking at how do we support how do we
better support data bricks um
authentication and credentials and
things like that inside of posit connect
and what does that look like those are
those are questions that we're looking
for answers on right now and and
thinking deeply about so there's going
to be some changes that are introduced
there all of that stuff will happen over
the course of next year so lake house
applications I think it's it's something
that's will be sometime towards the
middle or third quarter of next year um
and then there will be some work kind of
between now and then to continue
continue to improve the way in which
posit users and and customers and and
things like that can benefit from the
work that we're doing with data
braks okay I'll take this one can I can
I share a shiny URL within data bricks
without deploying to a shiny server uh
yes you can so you if you use datab
bricks notebooks and you run the shiny
app from datab bricks notebooks you will
get a URL that you can share with other
people the condition is that they have
to be able to sign into datab bricks so
if you have single sign on um and people
are able to just like sign in um that's
that's going to be pretty nice
experience they'll be able to access the
shiny app directly uh otherwise you know
that's not going to work but
fundamentally yes that is that is
possible okay let's go to the next
one I can't this one I can take this one
oh yeah go for it all right next one's
yours next next tie goes to you all
right does datab brakes obbc driver
handle things like spark ml library or
is it just more simple data PS data
access so obbc is SQL only um it's
essentially only going to use the spark
uh
API the data frame API and uh pass SQL
down to the spark cluster there's no
support through obbc for sparkml or for
streaming or for graph or anything like
that
okay I think that's our last for today
yeah go ahead James yeah no I was just
gonna say thank you everyone for coming
um we're again just to reiterate very
excited about where things are today and
and really very excited about where
things are going if you have questions
thoughts comments feedback feel free to
reach out there's lots of different ways
you can get in contact with us feel free
to take these things out for a test
drive and and let us know what you find
um and and yeah stay tuned for more uh
we're excited and and thankful for all
of you for for joining us today
absolutely thanks for all the engagement
for your time and we look forward to
seeing you next time